senior us officials say very serious
negotiations are taking place now on a
new Gaza ceasefire and hostage release
but Hamas is saying publicly no
additional prisoners will be freed until
the war is completely over the Israeli
military says it has confirmed a major
Hamas command Setter in the heart of
Gaza City the IDF calls it a serious
blow to the Islamic militant group
senior Foreign Affairs correspondent
Greg palott is live tonight in Tel Aviv
good evening Greg
hi Brett it was another day of pretty
nasty combat in Gaza between Israel and
Hamas with little sign of a halt in the
clashes Israeli forces on a mission in
Gaza hitting Hamas targets before
they're forced to scale back or take a
break you can see inside here deep down
a tunnel which was built for the last
few months uncovering another Hamas
tunnel this one in Gaza City 70 ft deep
with elevators staircases Plumbing
electricity then blowing it
up what I suggest for Hamas is very
simple surrender or die they have no
other
choice Hamas down but still not
out launching more Rockets aimed at
Central Israel including Tel Aviv us
repeating its call to reduce fighting we
believe um that a transition um uh you
know in the near future is is the the
best possible
outcome humanitarian situation in Gaza
dire the casualties soaring none of the
hospitals in the north are functioning
and all are hungry pretty much everybody
in Gaza is hungry about more than
500,000 mean half a million people are
starving as hostage talks appear stuck
Hamas rejecting Israel's demand for a
release of captives during a onewe pause
it wants a longer break even before the
talking I believe
the focus now is to stop this aggression
especially since our enemy now knows
that it cannot achieve any of its goals
as the families of the kidnapp weight
including the sister of Alexander
lobanov snatched by Hamas at that music
festival October 7th Alex is a lot of
friends that love him Alex have a 2
years old son that every day keep asking
where is Daddy and the only answer we
have that that is love
him
and still being considered at the UN
Security Council this night a resolution
that will call for a humanitarian
ceasefire and a greater amount of Aid
getting into Gaza that is reportedly
being held up by the United States as it
wants closer inspection of that Aid
before it gets into the war zone as
lives hanging the balance
Brett Greg palot live in Tel Aviv Greg
thanks we'll talk to retired General
Jack Keane about the military situation
in Gaza and also Ukraine coming up